العرض الجوي قد بدا امامنا الان ريما ونحن
نشاهد
الطائرات اذا حربيه وهي تحلق فوق قصر
باكينج هام ما هي التفاصيل هذه الطلعات
الجويه
بسبب سوء الاحوال الجويه في بريطانيا لم
يحالف
الحصي
لندن الجوي الى دقيقتين وثلاثين ثانيه وهي
تحيه سلاح الجو
هو العرض الجوي الذي فعلا بدا الان امامنا
ريما
الملك والملكه
واحفاد الملكه كاملا وهي وهم من ابنائها
واحفادها من زواج الاول احفاد الملك
تشارلز ولي العهد وابناء اصدقاء ايضا
موجودين على
الانظار الان على شاشه تتجه ربما ريما
لهذا العرض الجوي في سماء العاصمه لندن
وغياب الامير هاري كذلك
العرض الجوي بسبب رداءه الطقس والتعاند
بمروحيات وهي تحيه القوات الجويه
اذا تم اختصارها الى دقيقتين ونصف وكذلك
ايضا تم اقتصارها فقط على هذه المروحيات
التي نشاهد الان تحليقها فوق قصر باكينج
هام
لالقاء التحيه ايضا كذلك تقليد بريطاني
اصيل وعريق ايضا كذلك العائله
المالكه والاسره الملكيه ايضا البريطانيه
وهي تشاهد ايضا هذه الطائرات رفقه من
احتشد من الجماهير تحت قصر باكينغهام
لمشاهده الملك تشارلز الثالث والملكه
كاملا وهما متوجان
بالملكيه المطلقه في المملكه المتحده
الكاميرا وهي عدسات من شركات خاصه تديرها
الشركات مختصه تابعه لقصر باركينغهام وحتى
عمليه الاخراج يديرها قصر باكينغهام
بطريقه غير مباشره تصلط الاضواء على الملك
والملكه
وولي العهد وزوجته
والذين على العرش الامير جو
رج باقي ابناء الامير ويليام وبناته
في شاشه وهناك نوع من يعني تفادي تسليط
الضوء على باقي افراد العائله الامير هاري
لحظه
وخروجه من كنيسه مانستر
الاعلام
وغادر البلد لكن ليس واضحا اذا ما حصل
لقاء مباشر بينه وبين والده ويعتقد انه
ايضا المره الاولى التي يحضر فيها الى
بريطانيا وينضم للعائله بعدها الان القول
بان العروض الجويه الان
لهذه الطائرات ايضا التي نشاهدها الطائرات
السلاح الجو ربما الملكي البريطاني تختفي
الكثير من الانظار بهذه التشكيلات الفنيه
المختلفه بالوان
الازرق والابيض والاحمر ايضا كذلك وهي
التي ترمز الى العلم
البريطاني ايضا كذلك ريما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص سخطه على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات